break away
[Music]
what's your answer
[Music]
if I tell my mom and she tells your
mommy
now for a trip inside Trump worlds all
oh yeah and I put some extra mushrooms
on that Swiss there for you oh thanks
man I appreciate it
long week this will lie too but this now
the Trump presidency this is what a
crisis of leadership looks and feels a
quarter black every week another scan
would you say you got these mushrooms
again from a fan yes what club was from
Colorado Rudy Giuliana you see him there
on handed it this week
[Music]
you know
[Music]
drop the top of the shot where I stop
and I take all my life
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when you want
I'm making a crap
tell me tell me
let's be my lover but I'm a chubby
dancer
[Music]
okay
[Music]
see me Stephen I've been thinking about
that yeah
I was just
reporters and you were um
no yeah
are you feeling all right
same for Doctor oh my God
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's a confused sip uh
recoveries I I do not remember uh uh
where the kernel for the idea of that
intro was uh well you know but you know
what this is real man
this is real you're not gonna see that
I'm not on Ben Shapiro this isn't no
family matters
so uh we have a lot we're going to be
talking about
are you sure this is real life kids is
it yeah we've got gay Santas and we've
got uh we've got new CEOs of Twitter uh
we have some information on the new CEO
of Twitter I don't know how
how we managed to do worse than Jack
Dorsey but
that 100 wow
so uh we'll be talking about that and
some disturbing thousand I don't know
Sports I don't know but it's I don't
know I don't know what is a good score
for a touchdown actually we are it's
we're doing poorly so yeah that makes
sense yeah you're right we're betting
100. bad an old Hawaii Five-O
um and we're also going to be talking
today look we hear this a lot first let
me let me warn you guys this is going to
be a very nationalist show today so if
you consider National Pride white
supremacy this isn't for you you
shouldn't tune in somewhere else I want
to be very clear because it matters when
we're talking about people heading up
American companies like Twitter who are
not from the United States who don't
share the values and say that they don't
respect the first amendment that it is
of no value to them this is an actual
quote we will get to that later the new
CEO of Twitter I'm avoiding saying his
name because I forgot it
something uh and we've heard a lot about
how the right and the left are extreme
and right-wing extremists well you know
what I want to today
go through the left the mainstream
left's platform the DNC and the most
radical right pieces of legislation and
then you guys let me know what you think
is considered uh considered more extreme
so you can comment below and let me know
what you think is going to happen I'm
foreshadowing at this point but uh
before we get to that and uh gay Santa
and Elliott page Elliot there's no way
that I will not get pronouns wrong
accidentally just let you know it's
almost impossible with her it's almost
Dave just go I didn't even mean to Juno
is her milk Dud nipples on Instagram is
he I forget that I'm gonna just not talk
they look like like albino raisinets I'm
still getting used beautiful and brave
albino raisin that's beautiful before we
get to that Gerald a you can follow my
Gene Morgan Jr how are you sir I am well
sir how are you I'm okay haven't slept
much no hey by the way it was great to
see half asian lawyer bill in there he's
off camera now because he's working on a
lot of people he's working on around I
talk to him every week just about so he
can't be on air because bill becomes a
Loose Cannon and he'll say something in
incredibly funny but then they'll just
go I present to you exhibit B and I came
in a walrus costume doing an Asian Rose
Chef not good so uh but we'll be using
some sketches and stuff coming up yeah
uh quarter black Garrett how are you
Morgan what's going on yeah you decided
to go with the uh the least convenience
oh wow you possible on the other way I'm
trying to hide yeah this is like Seattle
grunge I feel like you're about to call
mom and ask her how wolf he is
and he's performing yes at the comedy
Cove in Springfield New Jersey and
December 10th Romeo Michigan at the
showroom uh at youngers Dave Landau Ahoy
how are you sir I'm doing fine yourself
good well you know what it's uh it's
about to get a lot worse oh well let's
I'm excited Elliott page and uh and
blatantly homosexual Santa
the Santa well no both yeah they're both
yeah you're right on both counters wait
I think this or no penis I don't but
Elliott page is a Les I don't know Ellie
page wasn't lesbian and now Elliott page
is a straight straight male it's just a
dude it's a straight five foot one 84
pound male and a poonhound yes
can't get enough of it apparently
except Sharon his own what if that's
what it was it was just that there's
something that in your genetic code when
you're a lesbian in uh too much poonanny
just turned you into like a trans
werewolf
you wake up in a vagina hat right not a
joke and then you're in charge of our
Economic Policy so hey really quickly
because I have no idea if we're still on
YouTube uh the best way to tune it live
Monday through Thursday at 10 A.M
Eastern you can watch it here on YouTube
if we're not on YouTube we will let you
know if we are not streaming that's why
we need to follow us on all social media
but we are available on Rumble and of
course mug Club where today we'll be
doing an extra 45 minutes to an hour so
Monday through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern
regardless of what Susan wojcicki says I
just want to be clear
all right handsome woman yes yes
trouble today he's apt and just wait
till I get to the nationalism well hey
take a guess what country do you think I
believe is the best country in the world
Denmark well more important than which
country Norwood is that India sucks so
uh well oh sorry I mean when I say India
sex I mean inferior I mean uh I mean
fewer people want to immigrate to India
it sucks there's some fantastic
wonderful people but uh you know yeah
fun poop games some I'm sure the same
ratio of decent people as in any country
well like any country on yeah yeah but
for some reason the overwhelming
output of the country is suck a lot of
great ones come here yes yes I like how
there's a bathroom literally everywhere
it's true it's true there's no searching
very convenient no holding it in they
must have very healthy bladders yes yes
here they are doctors
he's a child
he's our kind of child that's his only
job is fart button yes
and Joe bidenberg same difference he is
the Babe Ruth of the fart matter of fact
sometimes before he pushes it he goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
so Norway's Postal Service Boston
Beggars I don't know yeah uh they made
an ad called when Harry met Santa and I
know what you're thinking um like well
that's
exactly what you're thinking it's about
it it's about a it's celebrating gayness
with uh uh a Santa who appears like he
might be one of the Visions from thinner
oh good uh so let's watch this right now
in case you haven't seen this Merry
Christmas we can't just well hold on
before we go to this
people always say like well what's your
solution what's your response oh how
about we just don't have uh uh blatantly
homosexual Santa that's all that's not
I'm not suggesting that's one thing I'm
just saying yeah we don't need it he
doesn't have to have Two Beards you know
[Laughter]
Santa Claus that's a great role-playing
song or a wonderful little medley about
adultery have you seen his his body I
mean the in the way he eats the man
hasn't had a good erection since the 50s
probably true yeah Oak yeah that's why
well that's why you see Alice but Mrs
Claus name is Alice he goes see Alice
oh boy it's almost it's almost there
I can't see it can you I taped into a
popsicle stick really you can shrink
yours she just comes imagine being Santa
Claus coming I'm like you can go around
the whole country in one night you can
squeeze your body through a keyhole but
you can't oh damn so your sleigh tracks
went right to that gay movie theater yes
like we didn't know what was going on
and broke back Tundra please Rudolph
told me everything I wish you knew how
to quit lying
um yeah yes yeah right and leave it oh
yeah kids leave a carrot out for Rudolph
yeah yeah
so this is I'm just avoiding this yeah
this is uh this is aimed at everybody
including children in Norway
um I would rather they be watching Let
the Right One In
that was much better was it Norwegian or
Swedish I don't care let's go to the
game the American version it was less
pedoy that's true yeah anyway we can
move on or as they call it in Norway
normal attraction
nobody wants an old and Maiden normally
26 over to Healing so
more delaying 18 gross and
here we go let's watch gay Santa for the
Norwegian Postal Service this is where
we are heck yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and
very dramatic
I can't hear the sleigh bells anymore
did Darren Aronofsky director yes did
Santa die of age when do the rock people
come in
is that a shrunken head Christmas
ornament yep
and Norwegian Billy Bob Thornton is yes
[Laughter]
open the door with his pants oh sorry I
thought you were a boy
foreign
[Music]
I'm not saying
have you off wait a minute I'm about to
shake I'm like a bowl full of jelly your
beard tastes like another man
do you do this at every house yes yes I
do I am Father Christmas I didn't know
Santa delivered to porta potties I was
wondering why that beard looks so
crunchy
want to see that court case you're gonna
I have here all these deals that was for
Santa Claus
it's called when Harry met scent I'll
have what he's having [ __ ]
no is everybody
this is gay yeah yeah
Santa's been to too many truck stops you
should see what that guy does to the
Easter Bunny when he comes to his house
how many houses did you not visit when
you were giving that guy a bath
[Laughter]
hey come on over here and sit and sit on
uh Harvey milk and cookies lap oh what
why are you ordering presents from
somebody else you bang Santa you don't
have an inn exactly you would have the
inside Lane yeah he knows what you want
this is gonna Harem of elves Christmas
whatever you want I don't understand why
it's like it's the birth of Christ okay
manger okay Santa Claus a saint right
Saint we understand this he's a Saint
Nicholas there's a story he gave up all
of his belongings yeah of course Saint
Nicholas probably looked more Turkish if
you understood but then you know we
turned him into a Dutch white guy but
now he's got to be everything has to be
gay every single thing I'll be honest he
looks more Turkish there yeah
oh
jingle balls Here Comes Santa Claus here
oh no no no
Santa Baby give him the answer Santa
gave me yeah calm down my chimney
tonight I saw daddy blowing Santa Claus
well Mama cried upstairs
oh horny night Santa has a boner Santa
[Laughter]
clause
Christmas music anymore Santa's nuts
roasting on an open fire on the third
day of Christmas Santa gave to me
a penis
[Laughter]
I just wanted to pause for as long as I
could
Frosty the blue man
on the second day Christmas Santa gave
to me HIV
but he didn't know Chinese
that's something I just put the magic
hat on for us like hey kids happy and
I'm being screwed up Oh I thought that
was a corn cob pipe in the streets of
North Philadelphia yes
for political reasons that's right Santa
I don't don't forget to put out your
pink stockings this year yes somebody's
been riding too many candy canes yes I'm
going to fill your distended anus with
presents yes if you're not a good boy I
see an empty [ __ ] Hat by the fireplace
he sees you when you're sleeping oh he
does oh no yeah no the point is there's
nothing look let's be honest with this
there's nothing wrong with uh creating
confusing sexualization for children
which is completely unnecessary sex
doesn't need to be brought into Santa no
not at all Santa doesn't need to be
grooming little kids for decades
apparently too I don't know I mean I
don't even think he has sex with Mrs
Claus did you see what he did with that
coke bottle geez I like how he's showing
the guy magic yeah and the guy's like
wow I can't wait to do you I've waited
all year watch me make your pants
disappear
look at how I'm undoing your fly with
magic yes
look look no consent up my sleeves oh
oh
you are on the naughty list yes and
Santa likes it that way
we've ruined everything yep pretty much
just look at the candy cane Forest
streaky so okay Waits all year long for
a hookup yeah yeah this guy's crying
like I'm sorry you're not bonding with
him if it's it's quite literally a one
night stand he's like oh Santa Claus
come back to me well I'm sure he's gonna
bang you next 24th you don't need to get
bent out of shape over it but that's the
only time Santa can think of an excuse
to leave the house or Mrs Claus yeah I
gotta go deliver all those presents yeah
it's like what you couldn't do the 23rd
right so how long about how long is it
going to take you to deliver presents to
every kid in the world I don't know it's
my cross to bear I'll see you yeah but
why are you wearing glitter
get in the spirit
what you must have eaten a brownie
oh no all right
chocolate chips I'm not gonna be mature
about this there's no reason no there's
no reason to be there's absolutely no
reason what do you like what what am I
gonna I don't care we're 20 minutes in
and it's been nothing but gay Santa
jokes well that's their fault no I
didn't make the commercial I would only
have done it as a joke
they did it in serious next year he's
just gonna bang an Eminem yeah
[Laughter]
and it hurts he's just holding to him
and I'm together like a butt
pictures
they do melt in your mouth and not in
your head yeah
yeah I also melt
I made my heart give me 30 seconds you
melt my heart oh my God
but only once a year because I thought
it works
because I'm saying seriously seriously
let's get rid of the gay thing Santa's a
piece of [ __ ] but you can't call the guy
in October yeah you're not gonna invite
him to the North Pole we got phones this
guy's waiting with gifts
do you have any idea how lonely much the
field he's playing probably every elf at
the North Pole has he's just not into
you he's just not going to do the
reading like what did I do wrong dude
the guy can pause time and fit in
anywhere he wants to that's not the only
place he's stopping to have gay sex
dirty he was like his clothing was all
red yeah he's been everywhere yeah
that's at least the 38th guy he's seen
that day and he's like ooh magic every
single time it's the same trick exactly
well you know what not not that there's
anything uh uh wrong with that no yeah
there's so much
no I like that he's doing a take your
nose trick to a man he's gonna blast
you're not gonna need that nose
Hey where's the honk go
go
just quick for me to knowing you to find
out some guy just grabs his stocking
it's just leaking
I'm sorry I'm gonna get in trouble no
we're not that's totally that one's
appropriate yes those nerves I don't
know you guys comment I'm sorry did we
go up the rails too quickly I had a lot
to get to but I think this deserves to
be lambasted it does yeah deserves the
scorn it's just a giant box of some kind
of pudding yeah I don't know is this
weird I'm so strange this is just
bizarre well you know what I shouldn't
question his ways he's the magic man he
is uh got magic hands all right delivery
gifts it's the best trick he can do is
gut your nose got your nose
got your nose man got your immune system
get tested oh
no I'm kidding but I'm not I thought my
belly didn't shake like a bowl full of
jelly and I was wondering what these
stars were oh that's one for you I've
got a box of your dad's forgiveness just
like you wanted I'm kidding the key
there's nothing in there it's in the Box
you have to reach in for your
forgiveness yes oh like Mickey Rooney
with a popcorn pocket I'm sorry Mickey
Rooney not Mickey Rooney
oh original I say don't Sully the good
news
original bucket so
right
we don't make her too much noise
I'll go to the movies
all right speaking of this this
wonderful Christmas season time for a
little more Yuletide logs Elliott page
uh formerly known as Ellen Page yeah
terrible actress uh broke the English
yesterday I don't know about this selfie
in the mirror
second look even we edited the Santa
thing we have kids watching sorry my
YouTube nudity guidelines
uh let's bring it up again
yes better okay yeah thank you okay yeah
much better
what don't yeah don't even uh the uh
is Santa giving him something
the good thing though that Ellen Page
found also found a brave and beautiful
job so there's that yeah um
Ellen son of a Elliott son of an Ellen
well look he was talking about the
former talk show host yes who abuses her
staff yeah it was a horrible person as
opposed to her uh her and don't suppose
the Santa who abuses his staff as
opposed to Elliot no no no no no no
that's not get it right Santa doesn't
abuse his staff he abuses your staff oh
no that ripped I could park the Red Sea
with that thing so speaking of Red Sea I
should stop here's the thing with Ellen
Page and this is this is not a joke you
know how like Caitlyn Jenner when
Caitlyn Jenner becomes a woman yeah
right it's a stereotype of a woman when
Bruce Jenner becomes Caitlyn Jenner oh
I'll put on a dress and make up and goes
oh Brave and beautiful something will be
considered a sexist archetype same thing
when you have
ladies females who become who identify
as men they don't like become just a
just like a male Pastor or just a you
know a male it's a normal ability man
they they become Chaz Bono with a chin
strap and the guy taking Geraldo Rivera
douche picks in the mirror and by the
way Ellen Page Elliott page is five foot
one I guarantee you Elliot page does not
weigh more than 90 pounds he wouldn't
say Brave and beautiful you would think
if it was any other guy that he has an
eating disorder let's stop being crazy I
mean Chaz Bono just become Joey Fatone
yeah pretty much I thought that's what
that was I think I'm not sure that they
met in the Mary is a different person I
don't think it is
his name spells fat one I mean he was
the fat one he was
oh poor guy yeah you know what I see him
on every other Hallmark Christmas movie
that's true
I'm in Melissa Joan Hart oh the thing
about Melissa Joan Hart I have nothing
against her personally but I want to
throw her out a window just because of
the ACT everything everything what
how am I always get surprised just stop
being a thing do you know that there's
like three Hallmark channels now yeah
sure really I'm not kidding apparently
so many people love terrible Christmas
there's three Hallmark channels three
Hallmark channels can someone confirm
this in chat I think it was on YouTube
TV or something he's very forthcoming
about it yeah I know I was like yeah
that was another Hallmark we was like
yeah I paid for pay for my house in
Spain I play a waiter in a Hallmark
movie I don't care did you no no I would
though
oh yeah I'd be happy later and grow they
shot a Hallmark movie in Grand Rapids
and they didn't even shut down the town
they'd even let people know they were
filming or ask for release nobody cares
they were just like what are those
cameras doing around Rosa Parks uh
skating rink like this don't worry about
it okay uh let me move right up so let's
go right on here to the Twitter CEO so
this is important uh because we actually
caught something exclusive yesterday
before anyone else has sort of reported
on it yeah uh Jack Dorsey and I want to
know if you think this is going to be
the end of Twitter people have been sort
of foreshadowing that for a while uh but
it hasn't gotten any better and it's
still around Twitter is the least in
touch with real life of all the social
media platforms it really is celebrities
and politicians it's a little different
than say even Instagram yeah or Once
Upon a Time YouTube or Facebook Twitter
just seems to be every trend is the
worst kind of echo chamber so yesterday
we covered the Jack Dorsey uh was
resigning and he named his successor we
have some more information now but we
pulled this up yesterday Live uh parag
agrawal I'm just going to call him parag
from now on yeah and we found this crazy
old tweet of his here's a clip from
yesterday's show one quick update too
for the Dorsey story so he earlier today
was announced that he was expected to
resign he posted I resigned from Twitter
and his uh
his successor is a guy named parag
agraval we found a good tweet from him
if they're not going to make a
distinction between Muslims and
extremists then why should I distinguish
between white people and racists oh well
good new leader of Twitter how about
that I forgot that I did that because
you see that uh the folks at media
matter said on YouTube Stephen Crowder
links Islam and extremists huh as
according to
quit no that was him oh well hope you
enjoy them Soros checks so uh they do
they do like get into attic so Agarwal
uh he was Twitter's former Chief
technology officer this morning he was
named CEO because he is Jack dorsey's
most fitting successor and Twitter uh
banned sharing photos of private
individuals without their consent and
videos yeah the morning after he was
named CEO I mean do I have this right
surprising immediate immediate like
first course of action pretty much bro
and here's something too that you need
to understand
before I get into the reason for this on
YouTube there's something called dual
party and say and this is all about the
United States of America and people have
no respect for it in positions of
authority of companies that are more
powerful than governments who are
appealing to International interests but
benefit from section 230 under the guise
of being a digital Town Square okay I
want to be very very clear if this
sounds nationalistic and it pisses you
off that's because it is it it has
nothing to do with race and everything
to do with the fact that this country is
better than other countries especially
as it applies to Freedom an example of
this single party versus dual party
consent laws these are states where you
can record someone without their
permission okay Most states are single
party consent laws I believe there are
11 that are dual party consent laws if
you didn't have single party consent
laws you wouldn't be able to do
investigative journalism no one could
ever be caught in corruption you
wouldn't have a Watergate you wouldn't
have uh people will say prop but project
Veritas has some great examples but
basically every single uncovering of
corruption be it through media or me too
if you look at the audio tapes there
some audio tapes were used there was
evidence used against Bill Cosby in
other words how do you catch criminals
without single party consent laws
especially if you're afraid of being
charged simply for trying to expose
criminality so this is important because
and I want to go to jail really quickly
but on YouTube we've had this as an
example before in the past where we do
videos on the street uh and we would get
consent from people now you don't even
need to because we were performing these
in single party consent states then
people would go to YouTube and say I
want that removed even if they were at a
public protest where there is no
expectation of privacy so they would
remove those we said okay if we get
consent sure fine then we showed YouTube
consent sometimes and I said people can
remove their consent afterwards kind of
like how they view rape and so what
happens is as long as your content
doesn't fit what they deem to be
acceptable guess what they can remove it
the second anyone changes their mind
that's not how laws work the reason we
have single party consent laws in the
United United States is because of
freedom and because it serves to keep
those in power accountable it's the
reason that a lot of other countries do
not Gerald so just a practical real
world example you would have never seen
anything on Twitter and probably other
social media platforms if they adopt
this about Kyle Rittenhouse you have
never seen the video for yourself right
to see that he was defending himself and
all you would have had to go on was
white races travels across state lines
and attacks a BLM protester or two yeah
and that's it you wouldn't see this so
we don't want to violate the privacy of
the individual you mean the pedophile
that's correct yes yeah pretty much
seriously you wouldn't have seen it so
this is one of us yes and who's what
what parameter are we using to to label
private individuals or is it just
twitters this is the problem is they
don't follow the law and then they
create their own rules even though they
benefit from the law this is the problem
look when people say go out and start
your own I used to be a Libertarian and
then I realize it doesn't work when you
have people who have lobbyists when you
have people who are in bed with the
government and they're not beholden to
the same laws that you are all I want
with social media is for them to be
beholden to the same laws as everyone
else if you're going to benefit from
section 230 which basically allows you
to eliminate all liability based on
whatever's on your platform because you
are not an editor you are not a
publisher but it's an open platform then
it has to be an open platform the first
step is making them decide and I'm tired
of Republicans who when they were in
power did nothing you guys are no longer
our friends it was the most important
issue that you could have taken care of
and you didn't because you wanted to be
in the Cool Kids Club so they remove
photos private individuals now without
their consent this is the Twitter
explanation immediately after this new
guy becomes CEO it's part of our ongoing
efforts to build tools with privacy and
security at the core we're updating our
existing private information policy and
expanding its scope to include quote
private media while our existing
policies and Twitter rules cover
explicit instances of abusive behavior
that makes sense this up update will
allow us to take action on media that is
shared without any explicit abusive
content provided it's posted without the
consent of the person depicted that's
okay so hey hold on a second I now have
John Edwards on tape saying that he was
banging banging a pregnant woman while
his wife was in the hospital with cancer
and it's on well he didn't have his
consent and you're the one pan what a
cool guy
that's insane no I don't understand what
can be the justification for this
no so go ahead it gives them control
over everything in other words
how can you prove that someone didn't
give consent if they're on camera let's
say willingly giving an interview well
Twitter can just say oh you don't have
consent yeah we've determined that they
didn't give you enough consent it just
gives them control there are laws for
this so that hurdles have to be cleared
so that we look we have to abide by the
rules with on which we agree and we
agreed to these rules and you benefit
from section 230 being an open Town
Square now this guy explicitly he's the
worst ever because he doesn't he doesn't
because he doesn't even try and act
like he wants there to be an open
dialogue or Free Speech uh is even he
doesn't even want to pretend like it's
an important component to Twitter this
is as bad as Jack was yeah I think he
might be looking back on remember the
good old days of Dorsey never you know
our beard guy that guy yeah
oh Santa beard oh Santa beard guy yeah
he was waiting uh he got the wrong
schedule he was waiting on December 26th
he gets he gets Santa on boxing day he's
like I'm tired let's get this over with
Jack come on Santa I won't cut this
beard until you come back to me yes crap
oh some kind of like a playoff beard
only gay yes I'm gonna never wash it I
never watch the spirit birds will live
in this beard yes gay Birds
so uh here's let me give you some
information on agrawal
2019 he purchased a fabula artificial
intelligence for Twitter it uses uh it's
an AI sort of software okay it uses
Snopes and PolitiFact to combat
misinformation but I'm going to get to
how he describes misinformation but
first these are and this is a problem
with YouTube by the way uh they don't
let you know who their Consultants are
on what's considered misinformation we
don't know all of these people involved
we just know that it at least includes
Snopes and PolitiFact here's a reminder
of how biased snopes is uh with some of
their lie fact check ratings they rated
buying uh Biden saying you're not going
to get coveted if you get these
vaccinations as correct attribution as
opposed to what most should consider uh
false yeah what you could say are you
saying that yes he said that I didn't
think that was the point of your site if
I came onto this show right now and
without this context said hey get the
value vaccine and you can't get coveted
banned
band and Snopes and PolitiFact would
advocate for me or you being banned the
President says it and I don't think it
was malicious I think he's semi-retarded
he says it yeah and it's just fact
checked his oh it's correct attribution
well I don't of course it's we're
attributing the crazy [ __ ] quote to
the crazy [ __ ] former vice president
that's not the question that's not your
job his brain's just melting here's
something else you want to think about
how sinus how uh perverse this is in May
of uh 2021 Snopes published an article
claiming that the definition of
anti-vaxxer had never changed because
they were being challenged they said we
never changed the definition of
anti-vaccine right right yeah unless you
check they change it in October ah they
changed it in October they absolutely
did change the term anti-vaxxer now they
lied about changing it just to be clear
Snopes and I'm gonna get back to the
Twitter CEO but this guy proactively
decided to involve these people show me
show me your friends
um
they're in fact by the way I guess I saw
the fact check that says it hasn't
changed
um there have been no subsequent fact
checks on this uh and here's the October
1st 2021 definition of anti-vaxxer a
person who opposes vaccinations or laws
that mandate vaccinations but now this
here's the new one because that's bad
enough
it used to be a person who opposes
vaccine right vaccines then they change
they have a person who opposes vaccines
or laws but then they changed it to a
person who opposes the use of vaccines
or regulations mandating vaccinations so
this is what I say when people say
you're a climate denier Okay this is
what that means if you say hey the Earth
is warming okay hey I think I could have
negative effects okay hey I think humans
may be contributing to it yeah I don't
think there's a chance in hell that
aoc's five-page green New Deal is going
to fix it climate denier so right here
you could say hey I'm pro-vaccination
okay hey I'm vaccinated okay hey I'm
even Pro this fat this not vaccine but
mRNA uh injection because I even think
people should get it sure I don't think
that it should be mandated uh
anti-vaxxer according to Snopes yeah
who's the extremist just keep moving the
goal post just keep changing the
definition we change the definition of
vaccines so we should be able to change
this one too yeah that's true it's a
therapeutic I think more well we also
change the definition of uh man
well we change the definition of a man
woman right man bear children man bear
pig yes yeah yeah as you know now Saint
Nicholas uh what world are we living in
so uh 2019 Jack Dorsey picked parag to
uh to head a project a project Bluesky
not blue tarsky this is the actual name
Blue Sky to find a head for project
Bluesky this was what he was tasked with
let me read you how they describe
project Bluesky just so you know who
this new Twitter
I'm reading like a Polish name yeah I am
John blue the first one was written with
an i yeah Blue Sky hey Jenny Bluesky
hit the admonish button okay hit the
admonish button
yeah
monish it's your if you don't do
in the comment section I don't want you
as a fan oh Blue Sky
talking about Blues game all right blue
ski outside
Project Blue she zero point zero we're
all now Dumber yes
so uh Project Blue Sky
satisfied
uh I'm not
an independent team of Open Source
Architects engineers and designers to
develop an open and decentralized
standard for social media that would
help better control abusive and
misleading information on this platform
now you read that and you're like okay
abusive I got it misleading who's going
to be the Arbiter of what is considered
misleading well here's a 2020 interview
from an MIT uh technology review with uh
the new CEO agrawal I'm probably getting
that wrong too Agra Skye
here he is commenting on free speech and
misinformation and if this doesn't send
chills down your spine especially
considering he's bumping elbows with the
elite who are in control of your taxes
and your guns it should somebody in the
audience is also pointing out that
you're trying to combat this information
you also want to protect Free Speech as
a core value and also in the US as the
first amendment how do you balance those
two
our role is not to be bound by the First
Amendment but our role is to serve a
healthy public conversation and our
moves are reflective of things that we
believe lead to a healthier public
conversation the kinds of things that we
we do to what about this is
to focus Less on thinking about Free
Speech but thinking about how the times
have changed ah one of the changes today
that we see is
speech is easy on the internet most
people can speak where our role is
certainly emphasized is who can be heard
deciding who is going to get hurt or
which voices should get more attention
is just as far as the question is which
voices should be suppressed that's
exactly right I think the notion of
centralized content moderation
centralized algorithms is long-term
really really challenging
here's the thing it's not yeah it's not
let me be really clear people so you're
being reductive yep you think the
founding fathers didn't foresee this
here in the United States here in the
United States we have the First
Amendment for a reason it still applies
to the printing press
it still applies to your iPhone your
computer he says to have a healthier
dialogue no the only way ever to have a
healthy dialogue is to allow a dialogue
period do you know how I know because
there are no healthy dialogues
in any country outside of the United
States you [ __ ] about division I bet
you about people being arrested for
saying the wrong thing or like our
friend who was put before a human rights
tribunal and then ultimately the Supreme
Court in Canada for a joke this matters
because I don't know if you detected
as Joe Biden would say a slight Indian
accent there
um but he does come from a country a
little bit India
where they don't have free speech this
is a man in charge of now of an American
company that is given the benefits of
reduced liability section 230 meaning it
has to be an open platform without
censorship That's the Law just like a
utility your phone can't stop you from
even talking with your klansman buddies
to the four people who are still
klansmen so India's Constitution though
where this man is from where this man
was raised where this man was first
educated has no right to free speech let
me read you the Constitution this right
however is not absolute and it allows
the government to frame laws to impose
reasonable restrictions in the interest
of sovereignty and integrity of India
security of the state friendly relations
with foreign States public order decency
and morality and contempt of court
defamation and incitement to an offense
look there you have decency and morality
public order that's very very Broad and
by the way it's specifically so it's
Broad in how it can prohibit speech yeah
but it's also very specific in the
speech that it will ban so in other
words it's hey we're going to ban this
and whatever else might be you know a
problem for public decency which by the
way in the United States the left says
hey don't push your religion don't push
your politics on me pal when it comes to
India however it's all Eat Pray Love
it's wonderful well how do they treat
women
you see how he's doing the in-run too
right so to go after the Second
Amendment they said okay well we can't
Outlaw your guns but we can make the
ammunition cost so much it becomes so
hard to find that it's it's pointless at
that point right right we can't take
away your right to speak but we can take
away your right to be heard right yeah
so you can say it all you want on your
account but no one will see it right
it's also a Chris Rock bit
yeah it really is it's it's make bullets
500 each then you'll think about who you
shoot should be like can I get that back
yeah
because it's a joke yeah this is the
problem with all this though is you
can't have a conversation without
allowing somebody to have an opinion and
we if you take away but not everything
somebody says should be a fact based an
endless amount of research that's the
point well they also don't want facts
based an endless amount of research
that's unless unless it sides with
because they suppress evidence as it
relates to vaccines or you know the fact
that uh uh men are genetically different
from women they ban people for saying
that they banned the hunter Biden laptop
story I would say a hard drive full of
pornography pornography incestuous texts
and international crimes would count as
evidence and they decided they were
going to remove it so let's just be
really clear they're not doing this and
notice he didn't say he did not mention
truth and I'm going to get to what this
new see what's his name
I don't know I'm going to get to how he
defines truth it's even worse than
you're thinking but again back to the
Indian constitution it matters
because this is where this man was
raised he doesn't he may not understand
why the United States is different and
I'll tell you why I think that most
Americans don't you take it for granted
as someone who was raised in Canada I
know the fear of speaking out in ways
that could be deemed offensive by the
way dressing up in Black doing blackface
is it's it's not offensive not there if
you've done
provided you've done it nine times and
you're the Prime Minister yeah
the Constitution checked India
specifically prohibits speech that quote
promote
promote these are going to do this and
if you're more offended by this then
screw you disharmony or feelings of
enmity hatred or irriter because
different religious racials language or
Regional groups or communities or speech
commits any act which is prejudicial to
the maintenance of Harmony between
different religious racial language or
Regional groups or casts so look it's
very broad it's very clear they can ban
any speech that they don't like at any
time and now Twitter can ban any video
or picture that it doesn't like at any
time under the guise of oh you don't
have consent the law doesn't say you
need consent to videotape someone
committing a crime cast defund the
police and disarm the citizens of their
ability to police their neighborhoods
man we don't we shouldn't have cops we
should watch our own neighborhoods well
you can't film them committing a robbery
just being like listen guys is it cool
if I record all this yes
I want you to sign these forms you know
it's just so sorry I'm late I had to
stop at Radio Shack yes I just want to
make sure this is all right with you
guys ah they shot another one of us oh
well I know this is a sexual consent app
I just I made it into this consent how
did you know Donnie was recording you
well first I uh saw the giant recorder
and then I saw the Circuit City receipt
that was the equivalent to nine miles
long so then he asked me to sign a
waiver before he recorded us yeah it was
really bad work yeah you might be
recorded and put in jail is that okay
right that's fine yeah I guess I mean
look rules is rules so here's the thing
these caveats are often employed by the
government in India you could say well
that's written there but has it ever
applied one candidate's been applied I
can tell you that one a friend who's
been on the show who for a joke wasn't
even racist or sexist by the way it was
just an offensive joke uh in India 2018
a singer was arrested for singing at a
protest against the Prime Minister this
year a priest was arrested for
statements that were deemed critic
article of the ruling pro-hindu party
huh
and
is that not terrifying it is it's
terrifying that here's the thing but
people that if you live in the United
States you are not aware of the cold
dark world that everyone else knows
all the [ __ ] that you say and I mean the
stupid [ __ ] the idea of destroying the
patriarchy and that men and women are
biologically interchangeable that you
know even you shouldn't have to change
your hormone levels to compete in the
international Olympic Community all the
stupid stuff that you say Donald Trump's
a Nazi you're free to say that here in
the United States you can't even
critique the pro-hindu ruling party in
India without the threat of being
arrested and I know someone right now
said well I could have take them a night
well look that's anecdotal okay that
doesn't matter also pick up your yoga
mat so and it was a priest yes you said
it right you understand like you see the
priests arrested in Canada because of
covet yeah yeah or I guess Reverend's
past hold out of their churches it
happened in California as well yeah I
mean it's not I mean let's not not as
severe because there's Federal recourse
for things no no I know but not in these
countries yeah I think God it does here
but they're still trying to do it at
what point does this big Tech movement
though take over everything take over
laws of the land I don't know Dave look
behind you it almost acts like a shadow
government at this point it does it
affected this election and I don't mean
the safest and most secure election of
all time I'm not even talking about
chaining the election rules per you know
in violation of state constitutions I'm
talking about Pennsylvania that we know
statistically people said when they were
pulled maybe Mission Control can bring
this up it's been a while since I
brought it up but people said oh if I'd
have known about the hunter Biden story
yeah that probably would have affected
my vote it was enough to change the
election
just to be clear
it's just disgusting what a
self-centered bunch of power hungry it's
not even about being rich anymore it's
just this disgusting level of what I
would consider to be Psychopathic yeah I
would consider well they're all patting
themselves on the back saying so what
we're doing a good job Dave we're
removing hate oh yeah by having the most
hateful platform I've ever seen in my
life exactly yeah Twitter this will be
one of those things where it's not
enforced equally right yeah in your day
like reading a tweet about you yeah
you're really feeling on the outs just
go to the YouTube comment section I'll
put some pep in your step yeah that'll
make you feel good yeah you feel like
gay Santa before you know it I think
they put a YouTube terminal in on the
suicide bridge oh go ahead and read
about yourself a little bit if you're if
you're on the fence about jumping yeah
go for it and by the way this is
something none of us none of us live in
a fantasy world I understand that
allowing free speech allows for some
horrible people to say horrible things
yeah what people say well what's your
answer to that uh them's the brakes
that's it yeah the brakes yeah you learn
to just ignore it yeah these people like
me this guy for some reason wants to
don't wear me as a shirt what do you
know what the guys who wrote this were
dealing with right after they wrote it
people saying British rule is right we
should go back to Britain we should be
ruled by other like do you understand
that there was still another War coming
and they had to deal with people freely
saying this country these Millennials
CEOs they know better than the founding
fathers look I mean it's true just deal
with a joke put yourself in there I know
better than you can you wrap your
peanuts around the ball stuff
do you know how to spell cow g-o-d oh
Eat Pray penis both stuff can I get a
burger oh that's offensive oh this is so
much more offensive not doing a voice
they want you to think that it's like
blackface but I tell them they can go
[ __ ] themselves I am so glad that the
hinker's area no longer does that yes my
will no longer
longer people's history for Millennia
problem solved my friends uh my friend
David Neil who I grew up with their dad
was Indian and he used to make me do
that voice every night at dinner because
he loved it he thought it was so funny
because someone from India I was
watching uh uh this is a very new thing
I like blackface we understand
particularly as it relates like a
menstrual no I don't think that Jimmy
Fallon was racist for doing Chris Rock
blackface it was his friend I don't
think that Jimmy uh Kimmel was racist I
think that they knew what they were
wading into I think Howard Stern was
blatantly racist when he said that
stinky smelly and word about Whoopi
Goldberg and blackface I thought that
that was it wasn't funny and it just
like I was like yeah you know what maybe
you shouldn't have done that one but
it's very recent that they want you to
feel like doing voices yeah is racist
it's insane well it's not it's not I
won't play by it now regret no the funny
part is like the thank you come again
thing is like oh so you're making fun of
a group of people that own a small
business that's usually very profitable
that's the whole stereotype it's like a
lot of Indian guys own 7-Elevens and
convenience stores Oh you mean they're
doing well yeah that's a negative
stereotype now it's called The American
Dream yeah yeah or they came here and
they work in one for a long time before
they become I don't know a doctor like
if an Indian doctor comes in I'm like
all right I'm in good hands yes if a
white doctor comes in I'm like can you
go get an Indian yes was this a
diversity quota Mr White yeah
Dashie I don't care you know like uh
like uh two creams in the coffee then
you get me that something right around
there on the color scale kind of a mocha
finish a little darker yeah something
just no I mean it's I I mean I like you
yeah but I can see your blue veins and
your forearms you look like uh you look
like that [ __ ] from the from Pixar's
Brave you know what I'm talking about I
don't think you can fix my goodness
female Indian doctor yeah that's fine
yeah
better any any Indian doctor passion
yeah deal just get out done so let me
let me read you here from the same MIT
interview were you about to say
something I was just going to say
following up on your your bidenesque um
a bunch of surveys were taken and it's
anywhere from like one in ten button
voters wouldn't have voted for him to
one in six wow oh surveyed so 10 10 or I
don't do the fractions what's one and
six is that 70 17. on the low end 10
viewer voters for Biden on the high end
17 fewer votes for Biden just from that
one story Stephen uh did he win by more
than 10 in a lot of these swing States
I'm just curious oh and the swing States
no no no no no okay yeah no no I mean he
could go on to you know telling every
Swedish masseuse that he won the popular
vote for the rest of his life like Al
Gore but he wouldn't have won the
election he would not be the former vice
president no he would not be the former
vice president okay so let me get back
to to this part uh during that same MIT
interview when asked to Define
misinformation Agarwal said this
defining Miss defining misinformation is
really really hard no it's not as we
learn through time our understanding of
Truth also evolves no it doesn't so we
focused way less on what's true and
what's false kind of the whole point of
determining misinformation we focus way
more on potential for harm as a result
of certain content being Amplified on
the platform without appropriate context
like looking at someone who was a woman
for her entire life winning an Academy
Award now taking a picture of raisinet
albino nipples and saying oh that's uh
her
well that that's more harmful our our
definition of Truth also evolves
no now this is something that's very
interesting that that is very uh
under addressed
the understanding of Truth does not
evolve that's why I hate the term my
truth there is the truth now your
understanding of information my truth is
just a lie it's just a liar yeah in
aggregation our ability to disseminate
information to determine exactly what is
correct what is the truth we have more
tools at our disposal to be able to more
accurately assess the truth however if
you're not using those tools with your
North Star being how to most accurately
assess and disseminate truth those tools
actually become clubs against the truth
that's what's happening here our
understanding of Truth has evolved
really
how so
truth is you mean to say there's no
absolute truth no that's a slippery
slope that we all want to slide down
right of course kind of like well hey we
don't know if the hunter Biden uh laptop
story is true uh well here's a
confirmation oh we don't want to look at
it so we're just going to ban it
I will I'd like to direct you to another
tweet uh here's Donald Trump's uh
illegally leaked tax returns yeah yeah
yeah you know what uh that's that's
that's Aces or Seth Meyers one of the
two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wait
Donald Trump said peacefully and
patriotically protest ah you know it
doesn't matter we're gonna ban him what
about the Ayatollah seems like a good
chap
January 6th the most violent day in
history most violent day ever but
Kenosha was uh you know Cal Rittenhouse
went down looking for trouble well and
there was a card black people things you
know so showing the car drove itself
into some people yes the car drove
itself SUVs
I mean pretty soon we won't even have
sedans no you've seen the movie
Christine oh we all have yeah that's
what it's scary which ones oh the car
yeah Stephen King one I was thinking of
Simone the John Carpenter movie it's
good yeah Simone was not no no it was I
have a woman who's a robot huh I thought
it was Sim one Maximum Overdrive it's
not good but it's enjoyable or the car
it's also a great car great film yeah
good uh let me recap by the way what is
that thing in India called that I'm
trying to remember I think Kevin uh Eve
evening teasing Eve teasing what uh in
India for people who don't know
it's a practice it's recognized law in
India yeah Eve teasing Eve teasing where
uh maybe you can read the definition so
people and by the way yeah all
references available a lot of cutter.com
I want to know where the me too people
are well women will get onto a bus and
men are legally allowed to grope them
group grope
I thought this was Santa Claus's thing
earlier here the EU teasing
come Santa Claus now he's finished oh on
me that was really fast
there's there are horrific videos of
Indian uh women getting raped on buses
what now yeah what explain to the people
the practice it's not even a greyhound
and you'd assume so why do you think why
as a woman would you ever get on the
rape bus like shouldn't have chosen
Spirit
Well I don't think you know what the
right
persons just so we know you are unarmed
if these iftis so tell isn't rape in
front of the word bus a bit redundant
yeah they say this is not the right bus
all right guys I want to show people
what is a euphemism primarily primarily
occurring in Indian English use for
public sexual harassment or sexual
assault of women by men
how dare you and what's the uh what's
the legal status
in India Madison India because it's uh
it's something that actually uh happens
quite a bit and at the very least there
are no legal ramifications but it is a
cultural practice now here's the thing
and what happens if you speak out
against it when Eve teasing is just it's
like saying the word flirtation yes it's
just a wave it's it's creepiest
unbelievable I've never even heard of
this he's he said that it is illegal but
culturally it's still around like they
don't they don't yeah they don't please
it yeah if you can find all these videos
everywhere so it's frowned upon it's
frowned isn't it is generally frowned
upon okay but if you play with a couple
of fun bags on a Greyhound Uncle Vishnu
is not the wiser I think the problem is
it's not friend upon it's illegal but
it's not friend upon well you said
tomato I say grab her cats
unbelievable I said who you say rape I
say I want baby
she can do nothing I say we airdrop in
some authors and let the ladies defend
themselves hey it's a good idea you can
call me your little stowaway all right
so more like soulless playing oh my gosh
I mean look you guys can run uh my point
is quarterback if you just have a
government in charge of what is allowed
to be spoken what is not and more
importantly now if that is as a proxy to
that is can you think of any government
go throughout all of uh human history
look at any Empire okay look at the
Romans look at the Greeks look at the
Ottomans look at the Mongols
look at the English and look at the
English Empire okay have any of them
actually been more powerful than this
conglomeration of alphabet which is
Google YouTube Facebook Twitter Apple
Microsoft Amazon
because these people all ban speech or
content at the same time that doesn't
happen by accident they act like a group
like a school like a pack
can you think of any government that has
been more powerful on a global scale
than this corporate oligarchy
effectively and honestly this is very
very different this is only taken place
it's only transpired in the last 10
years
and here's what's even scarier because
when we were kids you didn't have that
when we were kids you know you had like
people like oh that's that Powerhouse of
a company uh Milton Bradley you know
what I mean like oh yeah they made a
killing on Don't Wake Daddy now it's
like it's these are these are peanuts
right they're not even something they
wouldn't even register big Radio Flyer
they really did well with barrel of
monkeys boy I wish I got in on that
Crown floor
whereas now you have these so 10 years
exactly yeah 10 years
but now really in the last what would
you say five six years
you have the most powerful companies
that have ever existed more powerful
than almost any Empire that's ever
existed and now they're placing people
at the heads of these companies who say
we don't believe in the First Amendment
we don't follow free speech and our
understanding of Truth has evolved and
it's more important about reducing harm
and making sure that the right people
are heard and they never are held
accountable in determining who the right
people are in being heard and guess what
that's not only how elections are
changed that's not only how your
freedoms are eroded but that's how evil
horrible people
stay in power
and then we wonder
when this corruption gets Unearthed how
could Harvey Weinstein have done it I
don't know maybe people running
interference for him determining which
voices deserve to be heard and which
ones don't
how could uh how could Hunter Biden have
thrown a gun in a dumpster at a grade
school smoked parmesan cheese sexted his
niece and had such how could Jeffrey
Epstein have had a sex Island and a rape
shower I don't know maybe for the same
reason that the people who were running
interference for him all along aren't
covering the trial
and we have the most powerful companies
that have ever existed and now in the
last few years
they have selected
there's another way to say it
totalitarians
woke totalitarians in charge of what
information is deemed acceptable and not
so I say this new CEO of Twitter you
guys can let me know what you think
who's scarier but uh I think we are
going to look back fondly on the
memories of little old communist Jack
Jack Dorsey it looks like it's time for
you to close you were like a punk rock
hit if you look at pictures of you back
in the day you've got if you pulled up
the sleeves you have a tattoo I have a
tattoo I would not go away from that I'm
still a punk
endings and beginnings
are ending and beginning now
you famously eat once a day the first
week you start doing it it feels you
kind of like have a superpower yeah
we haven't done a great job what was
amazing to me about Punk scene and why I
got into it is because there was this
confidence or I'm not going to go off
and be shy about learning people have
felt that I don't want to be on this
platform anymore because I'm being
harassed and abused and I need to get
the hell out well people harass and
abuse me all day and I don't do anything
about that
foreign
[Music]
pool said that I just want to point that
out I harass and abuse him all the time
he was talking about me that's true oh
that is true it's our thing all right oh
have you been a good boy this year
you've kept your beanie on for all
recordings haven't you
by the way uh heaven and nose ring does
not make you punk rock it just makes you
a girl yes well hey that's a loaded term
these days hey smash the like button if
you're watching on YouTube right now
smash that like button uh and
I'm going to I'm going to end right now
with this look people got really mad at
Rush Limbaugh when he said that he hoped
Barack Obama failed yeah uh of course he
wasn't hoping that America fails he was
hoping that Barack Obama failed to
implement his agenda so that America
could remain standing
Agarwal I absolutely hope you fail in
implementing every measure that is on
the record references available at
letterscredit.com uh I hope you fail
miserably and I hope that people
I hope that people rise up and tell you
just how wrong you are I hope that Mr
have to read it Agarwal fails Youtube
all right